good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-3208
object class
ketter
special containment procedures public
knowledge of scp-3208 is to be
controlled by foundation personnel
members of mobile task force mu 7 the
whirlwinds are to search all available
media for signs of scp-3208 infected
individuals in order to enact isolation
and quarantine
individuals suffering from scp-3208
infection are to be isolated from
uninfected individuals and removed to
the foundation hazardous quarantine
facility nearest to the location they
are apprehended
analysis of scp-3208 related growths are
to be undertaken under supervision from
a hazardous materials expert interaction
with 3208 infected individuals after
quarantine even for the purposes of
analysis and research requires approval
from the 3208 project head at site-81
dreams and hallucinations involving
scp-3208-1 are to be documented as long
as the scp-3208 infected individual is
capable of communication with foundation
medical staff
description
scp-3208 is an infectious disease which
initially presents as a minor headache
caused by a hard c-shaped neoplasm that
forms in the thalamus followed by
neurological degeneration symptoms which
accompany early scp-3208 infection may
include impaired cognitive function
seizures muscle weakness and upper
extremity dysmetria
scp-3208 neoplasms exhibit a dendritic
growth habit expanding throughout the
cerebrum over approximately three weeks
increasing the severity of the above
symptoms until the onset of full-body
paralysis notably none of these effects
appear to be fatal to the subject
following this the infection will cease
growth in the cranium and begin to
spread through the nervous system to the
remainder of the body exiting through
any orifice to which the growths are
adjacent with the eyes nostrils ears and
mouth producing external growths first
the material produced by this process is
organic gray in appearance and a
transmission vector for scp-3208
this material will continue to increase
in size outside of the body until it
anchors the infected individual to a
nearby surface
while neurological symptoms vary all
scp-3208 sufferers will experience vivid
dreams and hallucinations that include
the presence of an entity described
similarly by all sufferers this entity
is designated scp-3208
1. as symptoms progress
scp-32081's frequency of presence will
increase as well appearances of
scp-32081 lead to irritability feelings
of paranoia and unease during waking
hours which is independent of the
progression of scp-3208 related cranial
growth long-term sufferers of
scp-3208 including those who are near
the point where speech becomes
impossible describe experiencing
trepidation during both waking and
sleeping hours
addendum 3208 1 discovery dream log 3208
1
this is a dream recorded from one of the
earliest known infected individuals mr
jeffrey kent mr kent is currently housed
at hazardous quarantine facility 904.
there's this missing girl in town and
i'm trying to find her in my office i
don't know her at all but i know that
she looks just like my daughter i try to
find her at work but she's not there
my beeper goes off and the whole office
stares at me i call the number and the
guy on the other end tells me she's down
at the docks
i go down there and find this tall guy
with a wide brimmed hat
she's behind him so i try to go over but
i can't get any closer
it's like i'm on a treadmill
i start to run but it doesn't make any
difference the guy walks into a
warehouse with her and i can finally
move so i follow him there's a dozen
bodies hanging from the rafters inside
they're all the same little girl no
blood no marks it's like they're
sleeping
i hear a noise and i turn around
and i'm out in a field the girls are
hanging from the sky now but
they're all awake
they start to scream and clawed the rope
but i can't hear anything the sun is
straight above our heads
then a huge shadow comes down over the
field
and the man with the white brimmed hat
is looking down at me
i can't see his face he grabs all the
ropes out of the sky
and walks away with them
i wake up right as the sun comes back
addendum 3208 2 discovery dream log 3208
2. this record is from d9931
from site 81 procedural review as to how
he became infected during what was
supposed to be a routine sample
collection is still ongoing
i'm sure i was awake for this but
i couldn't move and there was someone in
the room with me
i felt like there were heavy weights on
my chest
the thing in the corner didn't even seem
like it was paying attention to me i
tried to scream but
i couldn't
it was just staring out the window
i looked over and i wasn't on the fifth
floor anymore there was this dusty field
that just stretched off into the horizon
i looked back over and the thing was
gone
then i looked back out the window and
was out there in the distance
and way bigger than before
it felt like i was laying there for
months
pitch black arms were growing out of the
ground like plants the whole time
they tried to claw the thing but it just
stood there staring at me
i finally blinked
and the field was gone and i could move
again
that's when i picked up the phone to
call for the nurse
addendum 3208 3 discovery dream log 3208
3
note the following is a standard dream
log filed by dr isaiah hostetler in 1993
after his initial infection
i'm standing in the parlor of my parents
old home in maine they have some guests
over but i don't recognize many of the
faces
i smile and greet people and serve
drinks and i worry about whether the
food will be ready or not when a phone
rings
i pick it up and a voice on the other
end says
come upstairs
i'd lead this parlor and move towards
the staircase i remember it was this
huge sweeping thing that some italian
carpenter had built for my great
grandfather a 100 years ago but now it
ascends into the ceiling with no arm
rail and i can't see how high it goes
i hear the phone ring in the other room
and i am suddenly aware that there
aren't many more people around
i look out a window and see fields
which i don't realize is out of the
ordinary but that house overlooked the
bay
i begin to walk up the staircase but i
can't find my footing i take several
steps then several more back down i
begin to feel very afraid
the phone is still ringing louder
and now i'm standing in the house after
it burned down the staircase in front of
me is unchanged but now it just keeps
rising up into the sky
the ruins are surrounded by fields that
stretch out for an eternity
i start to climb again and as i rise up
the steps i can see a figure in the
distance i can't quite make it out but
it's moving towards the house
i don't know how long i climb
eventually i see him
a man in a hat standing next to a
telephone the same phone i answered
earlier in the parlor
i'm back in the parlor he comes up to me
and i can see him plain as day
he looks afraid
he says
did you see it when i tell him i don't
know what he's talking about he recoils
blighted seed breeds blighted crop
he says
and his his eyes grow
wide
so i'm sorry to interrupt can i have a
glass of water my head is killing me
thank you
the man leans in very close
staring at my eyes
listen to me he says
a nightmare festers in the field
they're all seeing eye passed over the
empty cell
even the reaper fears what is being sown
he produces a scalpel the dream walkers
are fleeing
they would be like smoke before a
cyclone
take this
he hands me the knife you cannot stop
its advance
if it sees you
cut out your eyes
the road through the field will be lined
with corpses
but it may give you enough time to
escape
by foot or by blade
the room around us is suddenly
collapsing
the house is on fire in the distance i
see a figure swaying in the field
the blighted seed
breed blighted crop he says
it is too late for you
use the blade give others time
he's coming
he is coming
i ask him who but he's gone
his hat is burning on a coat rack near
the door
i hear a long low sound coming from the
field
i turned to look and
i wake up
15 hours after recording dream log 32083
dr hostetler was found unresponsive in
his room in the site 81 medical wing
along with a scalpel and the following
note
i think i understand now i'm sorry
dr hostetler was experiencing full-body
paralysis at the time he was found
despite being in the earliest stages of
infection several hesitation wounds were
present on his arms and neck though none
were deep enough to cause serious injury
dr hostetler remains unresponsive in the
site-81 medical center
addendum 3208 4 discovery dream log 3208
4.
note the following is the transcript of
audio recordings gathered from dr harold
lang subsequent to his own infection 15
years after the previous log
after i started complaining about the
headache dr tarnett asked me to come in
and get some scans done they kept saying
they weren't sure if it had manifested
yet or not but after last night there's
no questioning it
i know what i saw
i open my eyes and the first thing i see
is dust
it fills the air chokes it makes it
thick high above me i can just barely
make out a light maybe a sun that barely
illuminates the world around me
there's a road beneath my feet
and i follow it
as my eyes adjust to the dust and the
wind that's whipping up behind me i get
some sense of where i'm at a single long
road that stretches between two flat
expanses of dirt
as far as i can see in any direction
i think in the distance i see mountains
but through the haze it's nearly
impossible to tell
after a while i see something laying in
the road its features are half defined
like something out of a storybook that
you dreamed about and then forgot
it's dead there are others like it
strewn across the road now
i get the impression that they used to
be colorful but they're covered in dirt
and dust and in the dark their colors
have faded their lights have all gone
out
i keep walking and after a while the
road ends the dirt has covered the road
completely and now it's dust forever
this is when i start to see things
laying on the ground
a hat a ringing cell phone a diamond
ring some baseball cards and a pair of
pants
i follow this trail of discarded things
until i reach a field one that stretches
out before me in a long unending line
there are crops there
tall stalks of dry things that rustle
when the wind blows
there are more things on the ground now
and somewhere in front of me i start to
sense a presence that makes my hair
stand on end
it's far away
i walk through the fields for what feels
like years the trail becomes thicker and
i start to see other things
at first i thought they were strips of
rawhide like you see sold at feed stores
or cowboy shops when i pick one up i see
the faintest coloration of a tattoo
etched into it dark stretches of
blackened blood accompany each one where
the piece sloughed off before coming to
rest
i start to see hair
fingernails
teeth
the haze grows thicker now and i lose my
sense of direction i'm wandering through
the rows of dead stalks barely breathing
and all around me i start to hear this
sound it's quiet at first but every step
i take brings me closer to the source
like i've been drawn into it
it's low
and inconsistent and it rises and falls
as i push forward
i hear voices now
individual sounds make up the din
i take another step and the stalks
around me disappear
i'm in a clearing looking out towards
another expanse of dirt
in the far distance i see a city made of
light and color floating in the air
there are shapes dancing around it
things with wings and things made out of
fire and lightning below its green grass
and beyond its blue sky
against the gray and brown of the fields
and the dirt it is a beauty that i can't
even describe
a city of dream light and wonder
jerusalem
set on a high hill
then i see it
swaying in the wind
it's long and lean with sackcloth around
its body and a wide straw hat on its
head
i can't make out its features
in one hand is clutched a thick knot of
rope thrown over its shoulder
as my eyes follow the rope i see
hundreds or thousands of people
bundled together like hay
moaning and screaming
some of them i can see clearly
men and women and children in their
street clothes
their eyes wild in fear
the others
i can see the
dark strips that catch against the rocks
and just slide off
like rawhide
i hear my name
and i look up
there's a figure there one scorched
black and rotten reaching a hand towards
me its fingers ground into nothing but i
see it clearly
its mouth is open
and it's full of dirt and dust
it chokes out my name
again and again
i can't see its eyes
but it's staring at me
i can feel it
then it's gone
mixed in with the rest of them as
they're dragged across the dirt
i hear my name one more time
and then the sound it just becomes
another sound among thousands i watch
for a while longer
they get further away and the sound
grows dim
and then the dust kicks up and the scene
disappears
i stumble through the choked air again
for a time trying to find any respite
from the horrid wind
i fall
barely able to catch myself the dirt
gets thicker in the air around me and i
start suffocating under it the ground is
shifting and twisting beneath me and i
sink into it i want to pull myself up
but my body refuses the dust is too much
it obscures my sight and fills my lungs
it fills my veins
i see a pair of glasses sticking up out
of the dirt
the glass is broken and the frames are
bent but i recognize them instantly
they're hosted
and then i wake up
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to aletraon
zargeron
professor puffer
retalias
your local fishman
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
octo potato football match
hms lily
the almighty fish
sayo dio demnatus
the morrigan
karim el
ashmuy james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you